how do you keep getting lucky with all
your kids like you're supposed to have
one bad kid I mean like doesn't sleep or
doesn't eat like your kids are all so
good yeah Kanye wants to have more
though like he's been harassing me
how many more he wants like seven Kim
Kardashian has hesitations about
expanding her family with Kanye West and
we don't blame her no we don't blame her
at all hey guys I'm Courtney Tess and
they were joined by my pal ash crossing
let's go ahead and jump right in a [ __ ]
because on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Kim has a really sad reason
on why she doesn't want to have any more
kids let's take a listen I feel like the
world is just so different now than when
I grew up so I've been kind of hesitant
about having more kids just because it
literally keeps me up at night thinking
about how my kids will survive in a
crazy world like this the thought of
bringing your kid to a school and having
them not come home because of the
senseless shooting it's like every day
there's something so traumatizing that
just makes you don't feel safe
okay just up for some context this is
right after the Parkland shooting in
Florida where 17 kids lost their lives
so I understand why Kim is feeling a
little emotional yeah motions were
heightened then especially and it's in
the news cycle all the time so like you
can completely understand where she's
coming from and having that you know
constant anxiety
yeah and that any parent would feel that
way but let's also move on to the fact
that Kanye is so stuck on having seven
kids like this is a litter of that's a
litter of children that's a lot of
children it's too much time to change so
much Ashley yeah like I could see if Kim
was maybe like I want seven I want seven
kids because I want the same family that
I but she doesn't want it no it's Kanye
you know it's it's Kanye and we
understand he longs for a family because
he doesn't have much family but let's
talk about Kim who would actually be
giving birth to these children yeah and
her history with pregnancy complications
I don't feel like this is safe for her
no because she was told in in 2016 right
that she cannot carry safely carry any
more children so they had they used to
surrogates for their third child Chicago
and that was successful but do we want
to go through that again I mean I really
feel like a serious conversation needs
to be had on Kim and her body and that
should be her choice that's just my
mindful decision yeah like I think at
the end of the day like of course it's a
compromise but like Kim can't safely
have a child and also Connie like does
this all the time yeah so kocktails with
khloé' every popular Khloe I know the
show in general but he said it on
kocktails with khloé' that like he
wanted more kids and that's when they
had already decided to be sent on to
kids yeah he already got his boyish Lee
I said no way I was so set on my two
kids and how happy I was with my life
the way that it is but Kanye has been
mentioning it every single day lately in
the past ten days you've counted the
days yeah
like why is he doing this to me he got
his way is he gonna get his way again
what he guys think let us know I don't
know but he just keeps like harassing
her and being like you need to have more
kids yeah and it worked and it works so
we'll see if it works again or seven
though we're gonna go for three to seven
we're gonna go for four more kids I
don't know do you think that Kim should
budge on wanting more kids why or why
not
I say no I'm saying no - okay well let's
keep the conversation going in the
comments and we've got you covered on
your pop culture fix until next time bye
for now
[Music]